ARE ALREADY ACTING ON THEIR OWN,
CONDUCTING THEIR OWN
INVESTIGATIONS DESPITE ALL
EVIDENCE ON THE 2020 VOTE.
>> Reporter: OUTSIDE OF KANSAS
CITY, IN THE STATE'S LARGEST
COUNTY, THE CHIEF LAW
ENFORCEMENT OFFICER HAS JOINED
RANKS WITH PEOPLE WHO REFUSE TO
LET THE 2020 ELECTION LIE DIE.
>> HOW MANY OF YOU VOTED IN THE
2020 ELECTION?
PUT YOUR HANDS DOWN.
NOW, HOW MANY OF YOU THINK YOUR
VOTE COUNTED?
SEE?
THIS IS EXACTLY WHY I'M DOING
WHAT I'M DOING.
>> Reporter: THAT'S SHERIFF
HAYDEN OF JOHNSON COUNTY JUST
LAST MONTH AT A CONFERENCE IN
LAS VEGAS STILL QUESTIONING THE
VALIDITY OF THE 2020 ELECTION
RESULTS, EVEN THOUGH DONALD
TRUMP WON HIS STATE BY 15
POINTS.
>> REPEAT AFTER ME.
>> Reporter: THE NEARLY
2-YEAR-OLD CERTIFIED VOTE WHERE
JOE BIDEN BEAT DONALD TRUMP BY
74 ELECTORAL VOTES.
>> THERE'S A LOT OF STUFF GOING
ON ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED AROUND
THIS ELECTION.
QUITE FRANKLY I DON'T KNOW.
BUT WE'RE LOOKING.
AND WHAT WE'RE LOOKING AT IS
WE'VE GOT A WHOLE LOT OF
REASONABLE SUSPICION AND WE'RE
STARTING TO DEVELOP PROBABLE
CAUSE.
>> HE SAYS HE'S ASSIGNING
SHERIFF'S DEPUTIES TO
INVESTIGATE 2020 FRAUD.
>> IT'S A LONG, DRAWN OUT
INVESTIGATION.
AND FRANKLY THEY'VE GOT A LOT
MORE TO DO.
>> Reporter: THAT'S THE TOP
ELECTION OFFICIAL IN KANSAS
DURING THE 2020 ELECTION,
SECRETARY OF STATE SCOTT SCHWAB,
A REPUBLICAN.
>> DID YOU FIND ANY MAJOR VOTER
FRAUD?
>> NOT IN OUR STATE.
WE DO POST-ELECTION AUDITS, AND
WE'RE ONE OF THE FEW STATES THAT
DO THE AUDIT BEFORE THE BOARD OF
CANVASSERS MEET.
>> HAVE THERE BEEN REPORTS OF
PEOPLE WHO HAVE FILED REPORTS OF
VOTER FRAUD WITH THE SECRETARY
OF STATE'S OFFICE?
>> WE HAD ABOUT 12 BUT THEY WERE
NEBULOUS.
>> YOU HAD 12, ABOUT A DOZEN,
COMPLAINTS CONCERNING POTENTIAL
VOTER FRAUD TO YOUR OFFICE.
>> TO OUR OFFICE.
>> WE TRIED MULTIPLE TIMES TO
TALK TO SHERIFF HAYDEN, TRYING
TO HAVE HIM EXPLAIN WHY HE'S
SPENDING TAXPAYER DOLLARS TO
LOOK INTO AN ELECTION THAT HAS
BEEN CERTIFIED.
>> YOU KNOW WE'RE STILL
INVESTIGATING THAT.
IT'S AN OPEN INVESTIGATION, AND
WE'RE REALLY NOT GOING TO MAKE
ANY MORE COMMENTS ON IT.
>> Reporter: TURNS OUT SHERIFF
HAYDEN IS ONE OF SEVERAL ELECTED
SHERIFFS WHO SAY THEY ARE
LOOKING INTO MASS FRAUD IN THE
2020 PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION,
SOMETHING THAT HAS BEEN WIDELY
DEBUNKED BY SECRETARIES OF STATE
ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND DOZENS OF
COURTS.
BUT THEIR IDEAS ARE APPLAUDED,
EVEN ENCOURAGED BY THE
ORGANIZATION THEY'RE A PART OF,
THE ORGANIZATIONS PEACE OFFICERS
ASSOCIATION.
>> OUR BIGGEST CONCERN NOW AT
THE CSPOA IS ELECTION FRAUD.
>> Reporter: THAT WAS RICHARD
MAC AT THE CONFERENCE HE PUTS ON
IN VEGAS.
HE HAS FORMED A WHOLE DUES
PAYING ORGANIZATION AROUND THE
IDEA OF CONSTITUTIONAL SHERIFFS,
WHO HE SAYS SHOULD NOT ENFORCE
LAWS THEY DEEM UNCONSTITUTIONAL,
EVEN IF PASSED BY LEGISLATURES.
>> DO YOU THINK THAT THE 2020
ELECTION WAS FRAUDULENT?
>> NO ONE KNOWS THAT.
NO ONE KNOWS THAT.
AND PEOPLE CAME OUT LIKE WILLIAM
BARR AND SAID, OH, WELL, THERE
COULD HAVE BEEN SOME FRAUD.
BUT IT WOULDN'T HAVE CHANGED THE
ELECTION.
HE'S A LIAR.
>> SECRETARY --
>> HE IS A LIAR.
>> SECRETARY OF STATES FROM
ACROSS THIS COUNTRY HAVE SAID,
WE DO KNOW THAT.
THERE WAS NOT ENOUGH FRAUD TO
CHANGE ANYTHING.
AND --
>> THEY'RE LYING.
>> HOLD ON --
>> Reporter: HIS VIEW ON THE
ATTACK ON THE CAPITOL.
>> ANYBODY THAT WENT AND BROKE
INTO THE CAPITOL DESERVES TO BE
ARRESTED.
BUT WHAT THE FBI HAS DONE AND
THE WAY THEY'RE GOING AFTER
PEOPLE AND PEOPLE ARE STILL
SITTING IN PRISON WITHOUT
CHARGES AND WITHOUT TRIALS, WHAT
THEY HAVE DONE, OH, MY GOSH.
IT PROVES THAT THE FBI WILL DO
ANYTHING THEY'RE TOLD.
THEY'RE A BUNCH OF NUREMBERG
OFFICERS.
>> YOU JUST COMPARED THE FEDERAL
BUREAU OF INVESTIGATION
OFFICERS --
>> YES.
>> -- THE RANK AND FILE.
>> TO NAZIS.
>> THEY JUST DO WHAT THEY'RE
TOLD.
>> IT IS REAL DISTURBING TO HEAR
SOMEONE WHO WAS IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO COMPARE FBI WITH
THE SLAUGHTER, PEOPLE WHO
SLAUGHTERED 6 MILLION JEWS AND
MANY OTHER PEOPLE.
>> OKAY.
>> DO YOU SEE HOW THAT COULD
CREATE, I MEAN, A REALLY BAD
TASTE IN PEOPLE'S MOUTH TO HEAR
A FORMER SHERIFF SAY THAT.
>> NO, NO, NO, NO.
NO, NO.
YOU'RE TAKING THAT WAY TOO FAR.
>> THE NERVE.
YOU JUST COMPARED THEM TO -- YOU
MADE THE COMPARISON.
NOT ME.
>> ALL RIGHT.
FAIR ENOUGH.
BUT I WILL TELL YOU WHY.
BECAUSE THE NUREMBERG TRIAL
BROUGHT UP ONE PARTICULAR POINT.
AND IT'S, YOU CAN'T HOLD ME
RESPONSIBLE BECAUSE I WAS JUST
FOLLOWING ORDERS.
>> Reporter: HE SAYS
CONSTITUTIONAL SHERIFFS WON'T.
AND THERE HAVE SEES AN ESSENTIAL
ROLE FOR THEM IN THE ELECTORAL
PROCESS.
>> I WILL TELL YOU ONE THING.
THERE IS OVERWHELMING EVIDENCE
THAT CANNOT BE DISMISSED, AND
ALL WE'RE ASKING FOR IS FOR
SHERIFFS TO CONDUCT HONEST AND
FAIR INVESTIGATIONS TO DETERMINE
IF THERE WAS FRAUD.
>> NOW, FORMER SHERIFF MACK'S
CONTENTION THAT ALLEGED JANUARY
6th RIOTERS ARE IN JAIL AND HAVE
BEEN SITTING THERE UNCHARGED IS
PATENTLY FALSE.
THERE HAVE BEEN HUNDREDS OF
CHARGES.
SOME PEOPLE HAVE DECIDED TO
PLEAD GUILTY.
OTHERS, NOT GUILTY.
SOME ARE AWAITING TRIAL.
THERE HAVE ALSO BEEN MANY
INVESTIGATIONS INTO THE 2020
ELECTION VOTE, INCLUDING IN HIS
OWN HOME STATE OF ARIZONA.
THERE WERE OFFICIAL ELECTIONS
AND THERE WAS ALSO A PARTISAN
LOOK INTO THIS 2020 ELECTION.
AND BOTH OF THEM FOUND, ONE OF
THEM DONE BY THE ALLEGED CYBER
NINJAS OR THE SO-CALLED CYBER
NINJAS IN MARICOPA COUNTY.
THEY ALL FOUND THE SAME THING --
>> YEP.
>> THAT JOE BIDEN WON THE 2020
ELECTION.
SHERIFF MACK, THOUGH, NOT GUYING
IT, ANDERSON.
>> I MEAN, I CAN'T BELIEVE THIS
PERSON WAS A L